[Music]  ladies it's Sebastian hey Kagan a  whiskey neat sure thanks hey come on  bartender I wanted to make my order here  okay bartender listen up this is what I  want give me something like vodka but  not gin but something like vodka and I  want something with no carbonation in a  nice strong glass  I'm sorry my Beth we're sorry okay I'm  just gonna charge my phone is that okay  yeah  [Music]  hey what's up Joe in French class they  called me  Rocio Sebastiaan that's odd which means  mr. Sebastian of the tornado powerful  and nice hate hate Sebastian takes  passion but that's tough hey they they  want you over the pool table they called  your name yeah they wanted to our meter  yeah yeah yeah sorry about that  [Music]  [Music]